[Music]
colleagues welcome back to our place of
work with these words the UK Parliament
was back in action the Speaker of the
House John burka resuming the business
of Parliament proceedings which the
Prime Minister had unlawfully tried to
block emboldened by Tuesday's Supreme
Court ruling the chamber was packed with
MPs keen to interrogate the government
first in the firing line the Attorney
General Jeffrey Cox mr. speaker on this
Attorney General's watch the government
has been found in contempt of parliament
now it has been found in contempt of the
law doesn't he just except he hasn't got
a shred of credibility laugh
it was boisterous confrontational stuff
on both sides twice they have been asked
to let the electorate decide upon
whether they should continue to sit in
their seats while they block 17 point 4
million people
Parliament is a disgrace
earlier the Prime Minister cuts a
solitary figure as he disembarked his
Air Force jet at London's Heathrow
Airport his visit to the UN General
Assembly cut short the prime minister's
final engagement before leaving New York
was a reception for Commonwealth nations
where he again justified his suspension
of Parliament as preparation for a
Queen's speech setting out new
legislation it's one of the reasons by
the way we need a Queen's speech is a
kid on drag that drank that solution to
have a bold environmental agenda as the
Prime Minister's convoy wound its way to
Westminster through the West London
traffic Boris Johnson might be forgiven
for wondering whether he will last that
long the opposition leader Jeremy Corbyn
is being urged or goaded into calling a
no confidence vote but he's refusing
until Boris Johnson officially takes no
deal brexit off the table he has refused
to give the undertaking he will do that
no application is so far been made the
EU and so far as I'm aware no proposal
on a future agreement with the EU has
been made either that was always our
priority and remains our priority the
editorial reaction of the UK's
traditional news media has divided a
long predictable partisan lines random
samples of British public opinion reveal
a wide range of confusion frustration
and uncertainty in just 36 days from now
Britain is due to leave the EU but there
is still no certainty over how or even
whether that is actually going to happen
Paul Brennan al Jazeera